it was unprovoked but this is what
Russian President Vladimir Putin
Unleashed on Ukraine
Russia's invasion of Ukraine has left
over 100 000 dead and millions of people
displaced
but Vladimir Putin's War goes far beyond
rockets and bombs
this war is also an energy War
electricity bills are soaring work is
continuing in Ukraine to restore
electricity parts of Europe are going
dark that has resulted in really bad
disaster we're at a moment in history
now where energy has become a weapon
but we've been here before
[Music]
The arab-israeli War of 1973 sent an
energy shock reverberating around the
globe the organization of petroleum
exporting countries imposed its boycott
and within a year raise prices more than
300 at the height of the Embargo half a
million people were thrown out of work
so what lessons can we learn from an
energy crisis 50 years ago
foreign
Russian troops invaded Ukraine in
February 2022 the West imposed sanctions
Russia responded by choking off its gas
supplies to Europe Russia could
single-handedly push Europe into
recession Vladimir Putin is holding the
trump card Europe is facing a worsting
energy crisis ahead of winter
but holding energy to Ransom isn't a new
trick in 1973 the Arab members of the
organization of petroleum exporting
countries or OPEC stopped selling oil to
America and other Western nations in a
bid to stop them supporting Israel in
the arab-israeli war the Embargo caused
immediate economic pain around the world
but it didn't have the impact OPEC was
looking for the lessons from the 1970s
oil shocks such as the oil embargo uh in
the early part of the 1970s is that they
don't work
by the early 70s 83 percent of America's
oil imports came from the Middle East
creating an unhealthy dependency
security is part of the energy policy
for any country in the world but before
1973 the U.S didn't seem to be very much
preoccupied by this particular part of
the energy policy nobody was so much
thinking about the potential negative
outcomes of these import dependency when
war broke out news headlines were
dominated by the Arab oil producers
attempts to use this dependency to force
a change in America's foreign policy
they will reduce oil production by five
percent a month until the Israelis
withdraw from occupied territories
for Western governments it was a
potentially devastating blow energy
Economist Philip ferlegger worked as a
consultant during the crisis and advised
numerous administrations the Embargo
occurred at a point where the economy
was already Fragile the country was
confronting uh serious inflation the
Arab embargo in 1973 then
exacerbated the inflationary impact and
tipped everything into a serious
economic crisis
energy had become a weapon
the world economy was utterly reliant on
oil in the 1970s we were at a moment of
inflection when the Middle Eastern
producers were ready to seize power in a
sense over the oil markets back from the
West particularly the United States
up until the 1950s America had been
self-sufficient in energy production and
while it remained a big oil producer as
the century progressed it simply didn't
make enough for its own needs the
balance of power in global oil markets
had shifted and America's Reliance on
imports from the Middle East meant its
economy paid the price
the U.S economy was facing tremendous
difficulties there was deficit of oil
and oil products so there was also a
deficit of gas the resource-rich
countries they suddenly realized that
they can affect the situation by
restricting oil supplies 1973 dramatized
U.S dependence on foreign oil
during the Embargo American oil imports
from OPEC fell by nearly half over the
next few years the price quadrupled
the impact of the embroidery from the
higher oil prices was felt Global by the
end of 1974 we were in a pretty severe
recession
but despite the bleak
a
crisis
MIT was quoted in The Economist at the
time saying that if the Arabs don't sell
a soil somebody else will
Adeline was right America might have
paid more but the oil still flowed
the Arab refused to sell oil to a
handful of countries like the United
States for their support of Israel but
they continued to sell oil to other
countries and so once the oil made its
way to Marketplace those cargos were
redirected at a higher price with
middlemen profiting along the way to the
markets that needed that oil
prices went up
but the United States did get the oil it
needed just five months in OPEC lifted
its embargo without the US changing its
stance on the conflict or running out of
oil and the reason is oil is a fungible
global commodity every barrel of oil is
connected with every other barrel of oil
even though there's some minor
differences in grade and refining
qualities basically oil will get to
Market as long as there's demand
50 years old the West is learning the
same thing again
despite attempting to switch energy
supplies Europe is still getting oiled
for Russia only via India where it's
refined from crude and sold at a higher
price Russia is actually making more
money from oil today than it was before
the war hi
I'm Christian on The Economist European
economics editor we've written a lot
about the energy crisis over the past
few months and how it may affect the
world if you'd like to know more click
the link
foreign Russia is now making more money
from oil highlights another lesson the
world has failed to learn from the oil
crisis of the 17th
diversity of supplies being overly
reliant on a single supplier the way
that Germany relied on Russia for 55 of
its natural gas a couple of years ago
that is a a short ticket to lack of
security so diversify your suppliers
the oil shock of 1973 spurred a change
in the way the U.S government in
particular viewed energy security
let this be our national goal
at the end of this decade in the Year
1980
the United States will not be dependent
on any other country for the energy we
need
America began to increase domestic oil
production and started down the long
road back to energy self-sufficiency but
Europe didn't follow suit
in 2021 a quarter of all its energy came
from Russia leaving the continent badly
dependent on a hostile State the energy
shock that we're living through now
really began with natural gas in the
run-up to and during the Ukraine war
Russia squeezed Europe very badly
cutting off most of its supplies via
pipeline to Europe of natural gas in
2021 the EU imported approximately 83
percent of its natural gas around 45 of
which came from Russia as Russia
throttles Europe's gas supplies in
retaliation to sanctions supply
shortages sent prices skyrocketing
around the globe and as Vladimir Putin
threatens to cut oil production in
response to Western embargoes and price
caps there are fears the price of oil
could also get out of control now
there's some obvious similarities
between the oil shocks of the 1970s and
the energy crisis we're going through
today gasoline prices are high oil
supplies are tight and
presidents and prime ministers in the
west are under pressure to curb
inflation the scourge of the age once
again but Today's Energy Market is a
very different beast from 50 years ago
because we're hyper connected now
globally that means that shocks in one
place are transmitted much more
throughout the world that means that
we're more likely to see a globalized
shock in the crisis of the 70s gas was a
useful alternative to oil this time
around it's part of the problem
Russia exercised natural gas as a weapon
against Europe by choking supplies and
is threatening to do the same with oil
despite the recent drops in wholesale
prices consumer European gas costs
surged to unprecedented levels in 2022
177 percent higher than they were just
two years ago
Europe is trying to reduce its Reliance
on Russian gas but only two countries
have completely halted Imports Britain
which gets most of its gas from Norway
and Lithuania which has replaced its
Russian gas with supplies from America
but Russian gas is still finding its way
to Europe
for some years Europe will still
continue to use some Russian gas but the
bigger share of Europe's gas
increasingly will come from Imports by
sea that is LNG liquefied natural gas
where that natural gas is Frozen at
source and put on a special ship and and
said to be re-gassified on European
Shores but the West search for
alternative energy suppliers has had
unintended consequences one of the
tensions has been exposed by the energy
crisis of 2022 is the hypocrisy of
Europe basically gobbling up the world's
LNG paying heavy premiums to make sure
its own markets were well supplied
Western countries with Deep Pockets are
outbidding poorer ones for fuel
countries like Bangladesh Thailand and
Pakistan have been priced out of the
global LNG Market cutting them off from
the energy they need and more
importantly the global South stands to
suffer disproportionately if the West
ignores another lesson
the 1973 Oil Embargo not only showed
America the risks of relying on imported
oil but also the need to invest in other
sources of energy one of the outcomes of
that was a massive switch to color other
countries followed suit I think the
Germans would not and and the Polish and
other countries in Europe would have not
used as much coal had this policy not
happen the French on the other hand
moved rapidly ahead with nuclear power
you saw the beginning of solar power
across the world
for a few years it looked like the world
might be at the start of an energy
transition it triggered some things that
were positive that is a move towards
conservation for example fuel economy
standards for cars in America and some
other policies that did have positive
effect you might think a rise in Energy
prices would encourage a shift away from
fossil fuels but the oil shock of the
70s demonstrates it's not quite that
simple despite investing in Research
into renewable energies it was more
profitable to develop technologies that
made more efficient use of oil rather
than replace it altogether
today however the stakes are much higher
today the situation is much more
urgent than it was in 1970s we have the
climate threat the urgency of action
which the world has to make immediately
the current transition from
fundamentally fossil fuel based energy
towards something that comes after
decarbonized energy would take decades
and decades but we don't have that time
so it's the first time in human history
because of climate change we are
accelerating that pace dramatically
trying to do it in a decade or two
and that is unprecedented
[Music]
but the bigger Point here especially as
we think about climate change and
dealing with the energy transition is
diversify off of fossil fuels and find
Alternatives in power generation it can
be a new generation of nuclear wind
solar geothermal but as winter
approached and it looked like the energy
crisis could cause tens of thousands of
extra deaths across Europe and possibly
more in 2024 governments were forced to
look at Immediate Solutions there is a
risk that the short-term measures taken
by governments to cope with the energy
shock
like relying more on coal in the short
term in Europe to keep the lights on or
that kind of price subsidies that have
been offered in a number of countries
that actually end up encouraging more
energy use I think there is a risk that
this will slow down the energy
transition and could even lead us to go
sideways or backwards for some years
that is the great danger even with the
added threat of environmental
catastrophes there is a risk the lessons
of History will go unheeded the world
has learned some lessons from the
Embargo of 1973 but at the same time the
depth of this understanding wasn't
sufficient today we do not have time to
waste but despite the world's failure to
fully acknowledge the existential threat
there remains hope the gift we can take
from Russia's use of energy as an oil
weapon is that it seems to have reminded
the world which is getting very
complacent about the energy transition
that it's not just about climate it's
also about energy security and
affordability that our addiction to
fossil fuels comes with a very heavy
price
I'm Vijay Vegas Warren I'm the global
energy and climate Innovation editor of
The Economist
to see more of our coverage of
geopolitics and energy please click the
link and don't forget to subscribe